foreign
[Music]
landed on an Uncharted planet
we are the only survivors I don't know
where we are but there's something out
there
something alien
foreign
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
okay
what's up
[Applause]
we were gone for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
don't forget
where we came from
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
a beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
thank you
[Music]
and down I'm not the one to fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
over I'm not driving
away
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that is old
[Music]
in days of Legend
gods
walk the earth
[Music]
so yeah what have I told you
Athena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
thank you
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
you don't get to say that
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
[Music]
what the hell is that
you should probably run
don't let anything harm you ever again
I can have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
[Music]
we will
we'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
I thought we were friends
I have a new primary user now me
[Music]
did Megan do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan baby
don't be focused oh we will
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
we can help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
he can give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just had to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
we are a dwarf
we will annihilate everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
a lot has changed in the last few years
the wizard gave me superpowers
but then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
children's told the power of the Gods he
ripped it from our father's core okay I
feel like maybe I should be writing all
this down give us the powers child your
world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
please
save the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
searching for worthy champion
you've known exactly what must be done
really what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
started from the Platinum now we're here
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
again today
[Applause]
hold up
[Music]
Beyond it here
just reach okay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
treat them as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
first boy
if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe breathe
[Applause]
Outcast that's all they see
I see
[Music]
my warrior like you I'm supposed to
fight
protect the people
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get it done
[Music]
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]
tickets on sale now
what is this
see
yeah we are so alike you and I whisper
because we won't let this world crush us
but don't think that you can change the
Order of Things
the girls
The Citadel likes control
could open its doors to everyone there
wouldn't be enough resources
that's nothing
let's start again
whisper
she's not our responsibility she's from
sister she's taking us there let's go
go rooms Drifters Bandits
you have to be really careful who you
trust
the Citadel will be ruthless
that can't stop me
[Music]
you can change everything
oh
what happened to you
I don't remember
before I knew you I didn't really know
what I wanted in life
and then I met you and I feel like I'm
going somewhere
and I don't even know where but I just
know I want to go there with you
you ready to tell us what happened to
you
were you alone
you said I don't remember
I think something's really wrong with
her
what I'm trying to say is
you're my person Ruth
what is wrong with you
I love you but people change
Someday I'm Gonna Change
maybe you loved that new version of me
and maybe you won't
okay it's just I haven't been feeling
like myself
[Music]
what if I told you
that today
you'll leave here
I'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see summon above the
clouds that's big I'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
you ready
[Music]
here we go
I'm talking rich and famous for life
there's plenty of videos for flying [__]
online ain't nobody gonna get what we
gonna get what we gonna get the money
shot what's up undeniable friends with
aliens on camera the overshot see you
guys tell me what's going on hell no
cause I'm out here are you the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
a cloud pay more than that it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
I'll be rooting for you
I think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
[Music]
they gonna come back
are you ready
we got some work to do you know I'll get
him out
and I'll get the shot
let's go
I need y'all to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
well it's not what you think
he took
they took them all
I'm trying to save you my brother is out
there I don't think they take you if you
don't look at it
where you end up at the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
your wife is ready to go home her vitals
brain activity and Battery have all been
charged and are ready for companionship
you feel
feel
familiar
[Music]
they are people too they're becoming
more and more aware they need rights no
more sex slaves why would someone steal
a companion
it's not a stone line it's an
organization we're running out of time
Meredith
we need you to remember remember what
dude look at the guy her
she said she ran narrative off her path
on purpose
William told me how you people steal
companions you reprogram them to do
awful things I need to speak to Mary
inventor now she mentioned a man in The
Mask the one who hacked into my dreams
she says he and I go way back
how are we connected
I have a minute of your time what's your
name there
[Applause]
isn't love
I remember everything
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these are the amazing people I'm gonna
be spreading the break with group shot
I kind of wanted to save this prize but
whatever I'll tell you guys now it's a
smart house so I'll send you guys a link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you I'd
come through wow Andrew Collins you go
by Drew right welcome home
I've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what most people just call
me Marco
kidding me now go explore
come alone into my Paradise I have quite
the weekend in store for you
this entire place is one gigantic 3D
printer don't tell me you can't handle
it
working on from
can be out of these
I've never seen ai's this Advanced what
the hell did you do to them and I can't
wait to show you what outside
who wants to party
whoa what kind of Airship is that I've
never seen anything like it baby Glade
what is the president doing in our front
yard our entire world is in grave danger
I want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when he went
missing but now you're all we got Mr
Clay I'm a huge fan thank you [__] your
dad do you think you could Forge his
autograph what
where in the world are we
brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what
is this place the cliffs are alive and
the waters dissolve the flesh off your
bones everything down here is trying to
kill us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
classic Jager claimed I was
I was loving this family reunion come on
we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
she's not coming
[Music]
foreign
Legion Academy if you want it you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
great to meet you I'm monel this is the
rest of the academy trainees
during Justice
your cousin is a problem she failed to
control her powers Brainiac
I am not going to let you hurt anyone
else with her abilities that makes her a
threat I don't like what you're implying
we still have no idea where the rest of
the Legion is I've seen the dark circle
come on we don't have very much time
it's up to us so let's go be heroes
[Music]
thank you